طب لفتني في حديثنا بالكواليس عمار تقول
لي انه اهم القاده في العالم يتدربوا
عندهم ماستر على لغه الجسد مش ماستر يعني
وحده البروتين
اصلا في شيفره بين القاده يعني احنا ما
بيستدعونا نحلل الشخصيه او خطاب او ظهور
معين لرئيس ليش تلاقي العالم كلها بتنشغل
فيه لانه فيه شيفره يعني مثل ما في لغه
اسمها الاختصار والاختزال مثلا بالكاجبه
او بي سي اي اي او بي اي كمان في لغه
شيفره بلغه الجسد او في مدرستين بصراحه
بالقانون الماضي في المدرسه الامريكيه ولا
المدرسه الروسيه وحمله البروتين اصلا فهو
محقق 1,000 مره بحياته وممارسه كل هذه
الاشياء 2000 مره وصار اللي هو بيعمل لغه
جسد مقصوده ما في ولا حركه بيعملها حتى هو
بيننا احيانا فلان ولا فلان ولا فلان
بيشربوا لبعضهم لغه الجسد نقرا فيها ما لا
يقال او ما بين السطور او احيانا سر ظهور
نفسه
دي واحده شفت واحده بيحلل مثلا الواحد
اللي في الملك طبعا لا لانه هي اوردي ذا
ماستر من لغه الجسد يعني هي اوردي همم
مطور الجهاز كامل وهو اللي بيجيب
استعمالاتها بالمحققين او قاده او
اعلاميين مثل حضراتكم فكل هذه الاشياء
اللي احنا بندربها بطريقه حريصه جدا